what's this okay
interesting
how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have a truly awesome leak
that comes from a leaked set photo from
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier and
from the looks of this leaked set photo
what we believe it to be looks like it's
tying in Wolverine to Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and not only that but it looks
like we're starting to see the bigger
picture of the MCU tying in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier Black Widow and
other phase 4 and phase 5 movies to come
later on all seemingly connected by one
villain in particular that has a very
specific connection to Wolverine I'm
gonna break it all down in this video
but first congratulations to YouTube at
user Moore to Miss for 13 you are the
winner of last week's Funko pop giveaway
email me in the email in my description
and I'll get you your prize and this
week is going to be a black widow in her
white suit from the Black Widow movie
Funko pop all you have to do to enter is
subscribe like this video and comment
down below with your favorite superhero
or villain so there are just a ton of
things to break down today in regards to
Wolverine in the MCU including the
photos I mentioned in the beginning from
the set of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier and a new report from Roger
Wardell so first things first let's talk
about what ties Wolverine into Falcon
and the Winter Soldier
we have leaked photos from the set of
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
provided and posted on Murphy's
multiverse comm and in these photos it
reveals that Sam and Bucky are going to
have more than just one main villain to
deal with as it reveals a biker gang and
the biker gang itself isn't really what
Sam and Bucky are going to have to worry
about it's who they're working for as we
can see on the back of their gang
jackets is a logo and that logo is a red
flaming skull now of course this sparked
a lot of interest in the community many
people were wondering who this biker
gang is and what does the logo on the
back of their jackets mean but it seems
like the community has figured it out
and it's actually pretty clear now this
looks exactly like the logo for a gun in
the death of Wolverine Wolverine comic
as you can see the logo for ogen looks
pretty much exactly identical to the one
that's on the back of these bikers
jackets now if this is true and this is
in fact a symbol for Ogun on the back of
these jackets that means
Wolverine is being tied into the show
and the reason is because a gun is a
very specific Wolverine villain and
here's where everything kind of starts
to connect Hogan is the main villain in
the Wolverine comic death of Wolverine
and in the story there's a virus in the
Microverse which causes Wolverines
healing factor to go away so he can no
longer heal his enemies then find out
that he can't heal and Wolverine finds
out that there's a bounty on his head
so Wolverine sets out to find who put
this bounty on his head
after working his way through a chain of
villains he's directed towards Lord Odin
and Ogun eventually identifies himself
as dr. Abraham Cornelius the founder of
the Weapon X program this is the person
who put the atom in tiim inside of
Wolverine he is literally the person who
created Wolverine so obviously he's a
very big and important character now in
this story Wolverine would go on to kill
him and he would die himself but the
important part is the symbol for ogen
who is dr. Abraham Cornelius a symbol
that we see on the back of the biker
gangs jackets so this seems to be the
symbol of the founder of the Weapon X
program and we have had two major
reports from Roger Wardell one about the
Weapon X program and one about Wolverine
if you don't know Roger Wardell is the
Twitter account who posted a lot of
leaks about Avengers endgame all of
which ended up being 100% true and in
one of his tweets he said weapon X
Disney Plus show planned as a pre sequel
to the Falcon and the Winter Soldier it
will focus not only on Logan's backstory
but also other members of weapon Plus
program so he says that there's going to
be a Weapon X show and it's also going
to focus on Logan
aka Wolverine and it's going to be set
before the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
so this could explain why we see this
logo of the creator of the Weapon X's
program in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier again connecting Wolverine to
the series but we know that Marvel isn't
going to copy the comics shot-for-shot
they got to change it up and make their
own story and here's where it's
seemingly all connects it all comes down
to the leader of the Weapon X program
and who is that in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
right now it's Thunderbolt Ross and we
know that he reestablished the Weapon X
program in The Incredible Hulk
while in ww2 they initiated a subprogram
for biotech force enhancement super
soldier yes an oversimplification but
yes so the Super Soldier Serum comes
from the weapon Plus program which is
the Weapon X program just a different
name and then we see in the Incredible
Hulk the containers that have the Super
Soldier Serum in them say very clearly
weapons Plus on them so Thunderbolt Ross
has been running this program in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for years and
years now since the Incredible Hulk so
for 10 years now now we know that the
Super Soldier Serum is going to play an
insanely big role in the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and in the Black Widow
film and what we know right now is that
the Super Soldier Serum in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier is going to be
used to control us agent John Walker
when he becomes the new Captain America
he's going to be injected with the serum
but little does he know that the serum
is actually going to be used by the
government aka Thunderbolt Ross to
control him that way Thunderbolt Ross
has Captain America up his sleeve and
controls what he does
unlike in Captain America Civil War
because that's what Ross wants he wants
to be able to control the superheroes
and use them as he pleases
he doesn't want them going off and doing
what they want to do that's what caused
the civil war in the first place and
that's what he's going to be searching
for in the Black Widow movie as well
it's already confirmed that he's going
to be chasing down Black Widow and it's
already confirmed that this Super
Soldier Serum the red vials that we see
Black Widow holding are going to play a
big part as well the Red Room is going
to be using the serum to inject into the
black widows in their Red Room program
using it to enhance them but also to
control them at the same time so
Thunderbolt Ross the Super Soldier serum
and the Weapon X program are going to
play a huge role in phase 4 of the MCU
but Thunderbolt Ross just isn't going to
be himself he's also going to be the Red
Hulk which is actually what I think
we're seeing on the back of these red
jackets I think the logo is a depiction
of the Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross has
been experimenting with the Super
Soldier serum in the Weapon X program
for over ten years since the Incredible
Hulk and in the comics he experiments on
himself with the serum and that's how he
becomes the red
I think the same thing has happened here
because in the comics the logo is a
symbol of ogen and Ogun is really dr.
Cornelius the creator of the Weapon X
program well who is basically the
creator of the Weapon X program in the
MCU right now it's Thunderbolt Ross and
at this time in the MCU he's also
probably the Red Hulk already so this
biker gang could be working for
Thunderbolt Ross this could be his
attempt to try and control Sam and Bucky
because we know that Sam was supposed to
be the new Captain America but based off
of what we heard
Sam refuses because he doesn't want the
Super Soldier Serum that means
Thunderbolt Ross can't control him so he
sends a biker gang to take care of them
now obviously the big connection to
Wolverine is the weapon Plus program
Wolverine who is also Weapon X Weapon 10
is the biggest project to come from
Weapon X and the fact that the Weapon X
program has been quite clearly set up in
the MCU and the fact that Kevin Feige
mentioned at San Diego comic-con in 2019
that the mutants were coming means that
Wolverine is right around the corner and
he's clearly being set up in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier Black Widow and
according to Roger Waddell a prequel to
the Falcon in the Winter Soldier in a
very own Weapon X Disney Plus series now
recently Roger Waddell also mentioned a
little bit more about Wolverine his
latest tweet says the MCU is way more
dangerous place for Wolverine than you
might think
Logan receives his combat Nanosuit
thanks to cherie and antarctic vibranium
so not only is Wolverine right around
the corner but he's going to be
interacting with some of our favorite
characters and who else more perfect for
him to team up with in the beginning of
his introduction in the MCU than Black
Panther Sheree and Wakanda adamantium
and vibranium are the two strongest
metals known in the Marvel Universe
of course the metal inside of Wolverine
that was put inside of him by the Weapon
X program by dr. Cornelius as adamant
ium and of course the metal that is in
Wakanda the metal that Black Panthers
Claus is made out of in the metal that
Captain America's shield is made out of
is vibranium and it sounds like
Wolverine is going to get the best of
both worlds he'll have his claws made of
adamantium put in there by the Weapon X
program most likely at the direction of
Thunderbolt
and then according to Roger Waddell a
combat Nanosuit made of Antarctic
vibranium now what's really interesting
about this is that it ties into another
leak from Mikey Sutton Mikey said that
when the x-men come into the MCU Marvel
is also going to introduce the savage
lands and where's the savage lands
located it's an isolated region of
Antarctica and the savage lands is the
only place where aunt Arctic vibranium
is found so as you can see everything is
kind of starting to come together here
the villain of Wolverine and the Weapon
X program is being teased in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier and this villain
is most likely Thunderbolt Ross aka Red
Hulk so everything is kind of connected
here the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
Wolverine Black Widow Black Panther as
well the savage lands which of course is
connected to the x-men and we're
seemingly getting a Weapon X Disney Plus
show as well so things are getting
really exciting in the MCU Wolverine
seems to be coming very very soon at the
least we're going to see his setup
happen very soon so let me know what you
think about all of this news with
Wolverine and let me know in the
comments down below who you'd like to
see play him don't forget to give this
video a like and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things relating
to the MCU for live updates you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof